okay let's stick with the phones at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 anytime I see 7 7 4 I like
to go to it because sometimes it's Pat's
friends calling in to tell stories about
him call her from seven seven four go
ahead oh yeah go ahead right yep um yeah
like um I don't want to talk about them
to be I'm sorry you want to talk about
what a bumblebee no I the gun did meet
the gun did I yeah of course go ahead
yeah um I was like there's like a false
to beat like there's like the right
thing that the other position is for
banning all guns like how do we counter
that dialogue oh yeah I mean that's
that's straw Manning right which is it's
much easier to argue against an outright
ban on guns than it is against
common-sense gun safety regulations so
what the pro-gun fetishists like to do
is straw man the left as wanting to
confiscate guns like annek together we
can we got a call from someone who said
David are you in favor of gun insurance
and licensing sort of like we do with
cars and I said yeah I think there's a
lot a lot to that I think that's a very
interesting idea and I got emails from
people saying in reference to that clip
and YouTube comments you will not take
my guns David who's talking about taking
guns we're talking about licensing and
insuring them so it's typical straw
Manning Ryan I don't know the best way
to fight against straw Manning the what
if you're getting strong and there's
something to your actual argument that's
hard for them to refute that's why
they're refuting an argument you didn't
actually make if that makes sense
yeah we've got one new stock so like the
entry like end games mostly in a really
easy tonight externally I think it's
like either since then it's actually in
seizure of the things again it's like
background checks right the gun owners
they want the regulation so I kept you
know especially we can't wait pushed our
position
great like I don't know I mean listen
they control the dialogue that's the sad
reality right so if they say we need to
against gun grabbing lefties their
constituents think that there are
actually all these gun grabbing lefties
when in reality we're talking about
keeping a Second Amendment which we have
because we that's what we have but
working sort of within that framework
Ryan I appreciate the call really
important issue and one thing that
you're you know identifying that that's
something that's going on